escenas como ésta tienen a los expertos
en salud al límite de la preocupación en
india las multitudes se aglomeran en las
calles para celebrar de igual y este
sábado los mercados están atiborrados
por ejemplo aquí en nueva delhi donde la
gente compra adornos para celebrar el
festival de las luces yo creo que es
igual que en años pasados porque la
gente no estaba asustada por el hobbit
19 mirando a esta situación yo creo que
a la gente realmente no le importa y si
la gente está saliendo a las calles
la ciudad que recibe a miles de personas
para celebrar su pero un nuevo número de
contagios esta semana por encima de los
8500 algo que genera preocupación con
respecto a la capacidad hospitalaria
local pese a que los contagios se
mantienen estables
y también tiene un problema grave de
polución por lo que se podría agravar el
ritmo de contagios del virus durante
este fin de semana
con el mejor de los climas incluso en
verano eventos con aglomeraciones
generan un riesgo de transmisión
pero esto aumenta porque el riesgo se
vuelve mayor en climas fríos junto con
la polución
india ya superó la barrera de los 8
puntos 7 millones de casos de kobe 19 y
es el segundo país con la mayor cifra de
contagios en el mundo después de eeuu